welcome back well I'm not going to I'm
now going to introduce you to a new I
guess tool for solving derivatives and
really between this rule which is the
product rule and the chain rule and I'm
just knowing a lot of just kind of
function derivatives you'll you'll be
ready to tackle almost any derivative
problem so let's start with a chain rule
let's say that f of X f of X is equal to
H of x times G of X right and in the in
the this is the product rule and the
chain rule it was f of X is equal to H
of G of X right I don't know if you
remember that but in this case f of X is
equal to H of x times G of X if that's
the case then f prime of X is equal to
the derivative of the first function
times the second function plus the first
function times the derivative of the
second function pretty straightforward
let's apply it let's say that I don't
like this brown color let me pick
something maybe more pleasant maybe move
okay
let's say that f of X is equal to 5x to
the fifth minus X to the seventh times
20x squared plus 3x to the minus seven
so one way we could have done it we
could just multiply this out and this
one wouldn't be too bad and then just
Multan then take the derivative like any
polynomial but let's use this product
rule that I've just shown you so the
product rule just says let me take the
derivative of the first expression or if
H of X if we wanted to map it into this
rule well the derivative that's pretty
straightforward five times five is 25 25
X to the fourth right and then minus 7x
to the sixth and we're just going to
multiply it times this second expression
doing nothing different to it so maybe
I'll just
color times 20x squared plus 3x to the
minus seven and then to that we will add
the derivative of this second function
so the derivative of that second
function is let's see it's 40 X minus 21
X to the minus 8 and that times this
first function I guess I'll switch back
to mode I think you get the point 5 X to
the fifth minus X to the seventh right
all we did here is we said okay f of X
is made of these two expressions and
they're multiplied by each other if I
want to take the derivative of it I take
the derivative of the first one and
multiply it by the second one and then I
add that to the derivative of the second
one and multiplied by the first one
let's do some more examples and I think
that'll hit the point home clear image
change the colors and I'm back in
business okay so let me think of a good
problem actually well let me do another
one like this and then I'll actually
introduce ones that may be in use the
product rule and the chain rule so let's
say that f of X is equal to 10 X to the
third plus 5 x squared that's an X minus
7 times 20 X to the 8th minus 7 so then
we say F prime of X what's the
derivative of this first expression
right it's 30 x squared plus 10x and I
just multiply it times this expression
right 20 X to the 8th minus 7 and I add
that to the derivative of the second
expression which is all in one line but
I round
space 160 X to the seventh right 8 x 20
160 and then the derivative of 7 is 0 so
it's just 160 X to the seventh times
this first expression 10 X to the third
plus 5 x squared minus 7 there we go and
you could simplify it you could multiply
this out if you wanted or you could
distribute this out if you wanted and
maybe try to condense the terms but
that's really just algebra so this is
using the product rule so I'm going to
one more example where I'll show you I'm
going to use the product and the chain
rule and I think this will optimally
confuse you I want to make sure I have
some space and here I'm going to
slightly different notation instead of
saying f of X and then what's F prime of
X I'm going to say Y Y is equal to x
squared plus 2x to the 5th times 3 X to
the minus 3 plus x squared to the minus
7 and I want to find the rate at which Y
changes relative to X so I want to find
dy over DX this is just like if this was
f of X this is just like saying F prime
of X this is just the liveness notation
so what do I do in the chain rule first
I want the derivative of this term and
let me use colors to make it not too
confusing so what's the derivative of
this term well we're going to use a
chain rule first so we take the
derivative of the inside which is 2x
plus 2 and multiply it times kind of the
derivative of the larger expression but
I would keep x squared plus 2x there so
it's times 5 times something to the 4th
right when that something is
x squared plus 2x so there we took the
derivative of this first term right here
and then the product rule says we take
the derivative of the first term we're
just multiplied by the second term so
the second term is just 3x to the minus
3 plus x squared and all of that to the
minus 7 so we did that and then to that
we add plus the derivative of this
second term times this first term so
that we're going to use the chain rule
again so what's the derivative of the
second term I'll switch back to the
light blue the light blue means is the
derivative of one of the terms so we
take the derivative of the inside so the
derivative of the inside is C minus 3
times 3 is minus 9x go down 1 to the
minus 4 plus 2x and now to take the
derivative of kind of a whole thing
times minus 7 times something to the
minus 8 and that something is this
inside it's 3 X to the minus 3 plus x
squared and then we multiply this thing
this whole thing which is derivative the
second term times the first term x and
I'm just going to keep going times x
squared plus 2x to the fifth so this is
a really I mean you might want to
simplify at this point you can take this
minus 7 and multiply it out and all of
that but I think this gives you the idea
and if you if you had to multiply this
out and then do the derivative it's just
a polynomial this would take you forever
but using the chain rule we were
actually able to even though we ended up
with a pretty complicated answer we got
the right answer and now we could
actually evaluate the slope of this very
complicated function at any point just
by substituting the point into this
fairly complicated expression but at
least we could do it and and I think
you're going to find that the chain and
the product rules become even more
useful once we start doing derivatives
of expressions other than polynomials
where I'm going to teach you about
trigonometric functions and natural log
and logarithm and
and exponential functions and actually
up I do that in the next presentation so
I will see you soon